unas señales alentadoras en francia en
algunas regiones la presión sobre los
hospitales parece estar disminuyendo la
tasa de incidencia ha descendido desde
hace unos días en el default córcega y
mayor esto podría significar que la
quinta ola está empezando a llegar a su
fin pero muchos médicos llaman a la
prudencia los nuevos contagios siguen
siendo altos casi 330 mil nuevos casos
el viernes pasado y el descenso de los
ingresos en cuidados intensivos no
significa por sí mismo el fin del coi 19
power delta la ola de venta responsable
esencialmente de los ingresos por formas
graves de la enfermedad aún no ha
desaparecido
ciertamente ha disminuido pero sigue en
una meseta que está cayendo lentamente
aunque omicron disminuye masivamente en
los próximos días hoy en día sigue
existiendo el riesgo de ser contaminado
por delta y acabar en el hospital al
delta del hospital francia espera que la
pandemia siga la misma evolución que en
reino unido- tocado dos semanas antes
ahora en inglaterra y especialmente la
zona de londres el número de ingresos
hospitalarios lleva varios días
descendiendo sin embargo en el resto
para la quinta ola sigue estando
presente en alemania o en islandia
omicron apareció más tarde que en
francia por lo tanto ha llegado el
momento de endurecer las restricciones
en islandia por ejemplo los bares están
cerrados hasta el 2 de febrero mejor y
esperamos poder combatir esa propagación
durante estas dos semanas todos juntos
para aliviar la carga del sistema
sanitario y esperar días mejores
en esta isla de más de 350.000
habitantes se han detectado esta semana
una media de 1.200 nuevos casos a diario
en estos países al igual que en francia
muchos médicos creen que la vacunación
sobre todo de las personas mayores sigue
siendo insuficiente para lograr la
inmunidad colectiva